i'm lucy i make videos at GameSpot and
I've never really played Zelda it's had
my dirty little secrets I'm aware of a
lot of things you know like a who's
elder is who link is all that stuff so
kate has presented me with a challenge
of trying to guess what these very Zelda
actions are and what they do and I'm
really nervous that makes you fly no it
makes baby chickens follow you why would
you want that doesn't meet rabbits
follow you to make tadpoles while you
does it oh no make an indigenous tribe
of people follow you like sheep they're
not all about following I'm just gonna
give you that okay oh do you like wave
it at things and you say leave me alone
are they bell coins shiny rocks a crown
no go see oh my god no that was immature
Majora's Mask innocence it's just a
stick looks like like a willy warmer oh
I don't know no if you collect enough of
those do you get a Deku nut no you know
what day koona is you didn't earlier I
don't know but I think Gaston wore it in
view the Beast yes it's the Gaston tunic
that make you a [ __ ] uh that looks like
promotional item that got given away
with Saints Row three looking gak and it
a horse to combine your two answers a
ball gag in a shoe just turn you into a
pig but why to gain the pigs to us
linked into some kinky stuff I don't
know I think I've seen that on some
websites just a real phallic looking
unicorn horn thing it's a special stick
for conducting the wind admittedly this
hasn't made me want to play Zelda oh I
do want to play a car me again
come on this is